uh we will open up uh Public Works
further deliberation on House Bill 25
and I would like to welcome uh
Christopher Shea to take the uh
committee through the work that we have
before us here please good morning
committee members I handed out two
documents one's an updated
compare sheet basically the titles got
in straw poll suggestions you'll see
that lines are shaded and there's notes
in the First Column you also get an
amendment
House Bill 25 Amendment which
incorporates all those changes and I'm
going to walk you through the amendment
just to point out where changes were
made so that you have that before you
this is going to change after whatever
your work today but this was just to put
all your decisions potential decisions
from Wednesday into a new document in
the amendment format so you'd see what
it would look like several members had
indicated they wanted to see it in that
fashion
so if you look at the amendment it's
1061 h
on page one
if you go to line 13
you'll see number three two chillers for
29 Hazen drive for three hundred
thousand dollars
the next change that would occur would
be on line 16 and that would just be a
change to that total State appropriation
the number was
21331 500 it's now excuse me twenty one
two three one five hundred now it's
twenty one five three one five hundred
the next place that you've made some
decisions is in the Department of
Education beginning on line 22.
was to decrease the Hall Street
appropriation from 10.5 million dollars
to seven million dollars
and then the second decision that you
made was to add the winnesquam regional
CTE Center renovation for 7 million 649
663 dollars
and if you look at the comparison sheet
you'll see that these the things that
I'm talking about are shaded so you can
kind of follow along on both if you
choose to do so
you turn to page two
line three
this is a an adjustment to the drinking
water State revolving fund State match
as you recall that Environmental
Services said it was forty thousand
dollars too high so it was reduced down
to 10 million
448 238
dollars it was originally
um 10 million four hundred and eighty
eight thousand so that's where the Forty
thousand came from
move down to line 26.
and all that changed there was the
project title so it was expanded out
from Life Safety improvements to include
parking lot renovation and roof
if you move to page three
lines nine and ten this was a request of
the
imaginant General where to split this
project so as introduced by the governor
the Nashua hazardous material
remediation had four hundred thousand
dollars appropriated to it the edge in
general asked that you reduce that to
000 and then use the hundred and fifty
thousand to a new project of land
purchase Pembroke and that's what you
see on line 10.
you move down to line 36 on page 3 and
line 37 those are the freight rail
Appropriations
250 000 for Carol and Stratford
and 500 000 for co-ops
and what goes along with that is on the
top of page four
there's a note that requires the
Department of Transportation to report
to the capital budget overview Committee
in October and April of each year of the
biennium on the status of this
appropriation and the match that's
required
staying on page four on line six you'll
see that you added the community college
system
and on line seven it's critical
maintenance for 1.5 million dollars
you move down to um
row 28
that's the bonds authorized paragraph so
because you've added or changed money
we had to adjust
um
line 30 which is the total 235 771073
and then we had to adjust the general
fund amount
and then that will if there's any
changes to section one or two of the
bill those two numbers would be adjusted
again
moving you to page five
line 34.
so it's section 12 of the bill that that
is amendment one zero zero three h that
you approved on Wednesday
that includes section
13 and 14 as well on Page Six
so again that all came from the
amendment 1003h that you approved um
Wednesday
line 15 is section 15 of the bill that
is amendment one zero zero nine H that
you approved on Wednesday
line 21
is section 16 of the bill and that was
Amendment one zero zero five h
m
and then lines 27 through 37
and then on page seven lines one through
one and two is all related to Amendment
um ten zero two zero H that again you
approved last Wednesday or tentatively
approved
yep it's one zero two zero h
on page seven
line six which is section 21 of the bill
that is amendment zero nine eight zero H
again you you tentatively approve that
on Wednesday
line 27 which is section 22 of the bill
was Amendment one zero zero four h
so you tentatively approve that on
um Wednesday but you there was a request
from the committee to add some language
so if you look at the top of page eight
starting on line one it in bold it says
Appropriations contained in this
paragraph must first be applied to
construction renovation at the Powder
Mill Fisher Fish Hatchery and then any
remaining balance shall be used for
Statewide Hatchery construction and
renovation so as you may recall is that
there was some concern that this
appropriation has been around for one
biennium it hasn't been spent at the
Powder Mill Hatchery to address some of
the environmental services concerns
members were concerned that that needed
to be addressed before this money should
be used elsewhere and so that sentence
was added in an effort to um
help the committee feel comfortable with
that Amendment
on line five it's a new section
and this is section 23 it's titled
priority project list
so on Wednesday you talked a little bit
about if the CTE
appropriation for the winter Squan
isn't voted on by the members and that
7.6 million dollars needs to be removed
you want to have your wish list or your
priority list when you send this over to
the Senate to say if that money becomes
available this is the projects we want
or would like you to consider funding
this is something you did similarly in
the last capital budget as it related to
arpa funds coming in
so this will be amended based on any
activity that you take on that today
starting on line eight which is section
24 of the bill
it's called lapse of Prior Capital
balance this is the money that you've
been spending that's we've been calling
repurposed money
so starting on line 12
of page eight going through all of page
nine
to the top of page 10
you'll see that it's a through y
these are all the projects that had some
money that they didn't spend on a
project that we're going to try to
repurpose that got you to that three
point eight million dollars that you
you've been spending
um
you'll see on line seven
is an appropriation to Health and Human
Services of 1.4 million thirty two
thousand for the Glencliff wastewater
treatment Improvement
and then on line 10 is the 500 000
appropriation to the Connecticut Lakes
Headwaters Road repairs and Paving
and then on line 13
is the 250 000 appropriation for the
State Park parking lot repairs and
Paving Statewide
right now that that totals 2.18 million
dollars that is appropriated you have
about 1.6 million dollars left of the
repurposed money
um
to consider and and any of any of those
Appropriations would go in this section
and then um
so that
the last section is on 20 line 23 it's
section 25 and these are all the lapse
extensions and that goes to the end of
the bill and this is what represents
Jack and and the subcommittee worked on
earlier in the week to determine what
could come in or what needed to be added
and what could come out and so all those
changes have been made
there is
one
one typo on page 20
line 25 so in the
it should have said police Hangar
construction and renovation it says
reconstruction so I will get that fixed
the next time they do the amendment on
this and then the other thing that was
adjusted there was another two sections
that had a spelling error
um the piscataqua
River was spelled incorrectly so in
those two sections that we've gotten
that corrected in this version
so those are the majority of the changes
before you
at this point
and happy to take any questions
okay thank you Mr Shea again you're
talking about the error for the police
standards and training which all right
so we're talking about the bill the
amendment which page and which line
please
for police standards right yeah I just I
miss that what you're hearing the
construction reconstruction oh I'm sorry
yep
yeah so which page so it's page 20. page
20. yep
page 20 line 25 line 25 all right so it
starts police Hangar construction and
currently says reconstruction that
should say renovation to align with the
line 23 above okay
okay thank you representative Jack uh
thank you uh there might be on the uh
drinking water srf this would be
uh page two line three of the bill
uh the the compare report says at the
end says 83 and the amendment says 38 so
it would appear that the typo is in the
amendment page two yep line three should
be 283 rather than two three eight
thank you
so on that point and that's a great
segue representative Jack
this is a draft Amendment and if anybody
notices or finds anything in here that's
an error
spelling error or something's omitted
or is incorrect please let me know so
that I can confirm that it needs to be
changed
um better to have multiple sets of eyes
looking at something than just one set
of eyes
uh yes representative Jack thank you and
on a separate point now that we've
funded the community college with
something do we need there's a typically
a paragraph that says they can spend
their own money do we need to have that
or is that already in there
foreign if it's not there we'll we'll
have it added but I believe it's there
no it's not
yep
any other comments or questions at this
point
so we have uh Department of
transportations here Community College
is here I had a request by Gino Marciano
excuse me apologize for his last name
misspelling from the uh from the was it
Marconi
um that was had questions uh that I have
passed out a response here
and then once we talk about that then
we'll open up the conversation about
um you know expanding our list of items
that we want on here so
um
assistant commissioner
could I trouble you to come forward
please
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
David Rodriguez assistant Commissioner
of Dot
thank you thank you for coming over
the um
we had a
we one of our members had a question
about some other projects that we didn't
speak of and
um you're right on his behalf I'd ask
you to come here today and I believe we
have some questions also after that on
rail Improvement projects so
um
would you would you like to start the
conversation representative
oh thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
uh
thank you follow through on my request I
really appreciate it absolutely thank
you uh assistant commissioner
um
I contacted the other day just to find
out actually Dr Bill Cass but
um it was relative to your request that
you had uh in the big book and it had
not been uh approved by the governor to
be included
and and the question that I had that I
had at that time was that
um if in fact these three items that you
were requesting that was in the original
book
um there that there are all highway
funds
and the question I had was it that was
had that been considered in your budget
and did you have sufficient you know
feel you had sufficient funds on hand to
be able to handle you know the the debt
you'd require from these that that was
the basic question
yes thank you for your question and I'm
gonna pass that on to Danielle
Chardonnay a Director of Finance
good morning
um so yes we have already included that
in the debt service so the first three
items that are on that list that impact
the highway fund
have no further impact it is already in
the operating budget and has sailed
through the uh the governor's phase
uh thank you
and thank you again Mr chairman
they um I'm sorry I was distracted I
apologize so the um
the um in reps every year I just want to
make sure I'm heading down the right
direction here there there's there's a
project there that has interest your
interest which project is that
uh thank you Mr chairman well in
particular what uh caused me to ask the
the question was it one of the
particular items the first one construct
salt and sand sheds
um had the interest because of it in my
in my area uh there is a is actual
hopefully a move we can make we're
trying to do something for the rails
trails in in some land that is owned by
you right now you have some sheds
and it is in fact uh to be able to move
them you'd have to be able to let's say
uh build finally go through what the
project you wanted to do on South Road
which is also it's actually in
Northampton that you if we could take
those sheds down that are on the
property right next to the rail Trails
did you be able to utilize a a an
expanded capacity at uh on South Road in
Northampton and then and then we'd be
able to be talking more about doing
something else with that land
so that that's the original reason why
what prompted me to look at uh these
particular issues in general and and
just getting reminded of the fact that
it's uh that it's your funds and you
want to make sure that you know you've
accounted for being able to handle that
in your budget
thank you
thank you I'd be strongly supportive of
these are uh projects number 49 well the
one he's speaking of is 49 and then
there's 50 and 51 on the agency request
sheet that we got at the previous
meeting I'd be strongly supportive of it
since they've testified that they can
handle this in the highway fund and The
Debt Service is already provided for in
the Opera in the uh in the budget that
that the finance committee is working on
I'd be strongly supportive of adding
49.50 and 51.
those would be Highway funded
departments
um point on that please I I we're not at
this point that we're going to add
projects where I'm here to get testimony
and then we'll come back to this
so thank you and if I I understand
um what representative Jack is referring
to
um my numbering I'm not sure if it
matches
um but the first one would be construct
salt and sand sheds and to
representative Edgar's Point passage of
that will confirm that we have the funds
to replace the the Northampton salt shed
um the second one would be the
underground fuel tank replacement and
the third one would be the crew quarters
life life safety issues and the
department would certainly
um appreciate the the opportunity to
move forward with these projects in the
next biennium thank you I'm not sure
we're going down that list but I
understood I was looking for some
comment there any other uh yes please
representative Newman yeah
51 yes thank you
okay any further questions
thank you thank you
um
would you please come forward for the
Community College
I think we have a question or so for you
good morning
the I'm sorry introduce yourself I'm
sorry I'm Shannon Reed I'm director of
government Affairs for the community
college system of New Hampshire
thank you Shan
um Shannon and I had had a conversation
a few days back
with the hope of
adding either money into the community
college for critical maintenance and or
for the expanded programming that we
spoke of and the conversation at that
point was if we could only find one and
a half million dollars what's the
preference of the
of the college system and unless that's
changed it was for critical maintenance
which is what we have plugged in at this
point there's also been an ongoing
conversation
that many on this committee would like
to see that a new program started
and we're going to talk about that here
later today does anyone have questions
yes please
did I ask what the critical the nature
of the critical maintenance is just the
scope of what you're
our request encompasses a number of
different projects that include uh roof
work
boilers rooftop units some HVAC work
primarily
okay
representative Jairus
thank you Jim and uh so roof work
boilers seems to be a common theme
throughout the testimony of the other
departments as well
two quick ones
is it possible the students get to see
how that those projects are uh
being installed or designed I mean is
there any benefit to the students who
are working there to maybe
go up and take a look on to the
contractors learn from the contractors
or the engineers that's an interesting
question that makes me wonder if you
have been an educator in your
professional life
um I think there could be we typically
try to do that work when our campuses
are are as sparsely populated as
possible which tends to be during the
summer time but you know I see no reason
we couldn't look into that we do have a
at Manchester Community College we have
a building that's dedicated to HVAC and
it was constructed several of you have
been there it was constructed as really
a a learning lab every part of it is
open to students the the systems
themselves are part of what the students
learn on
um with the critical maintenance I would
imagine there would be opportunities for
some of that to involve students
thank you I I do you have a follow-up uh
briefly
roofs spoilers
any you may is renting in the design
that might include photo voltaics in
there
for the roofs or any uh
heat pumps
our critical maintenance request really
does not
um at this point involve that technology
we we have submitted separately a
request for federal congressionally
directed funding for fy24 which I have
no
ability to handicap whether that would
come through or not to do large-scale
solar installations at all of our
campuses to help you know reduce our or
alter our energy consumption but the
critical maintenance is really fixing
failing roofs making sure that there's
no additional damage to buildings from
those types of things
thank you
thank you Jim thank you yes
representative Abbott
yes I just had a question on your
request for the
respiratory
therapy program
um antiqued for teaching equipment and
teaching space renovation
at present do you offer a program on
respiratory therapy
presently not at Nashua Community
College presently River Valley Community
College in Claremont offers a
respiratory therapy program
in in conversations with health care
providers in the Southern Tier of New
Hampshire it became clear that there was
a real demand in that part of the state
for graduates of respiratory therapy
programs our plan if the if the NCC
project is funded is to create the
respiratory therapy labs and basically
import the the River Valley Community
College program to be offered in Nashua
doing it that way avoids having to kind
of create a new program from Whole cloth
and go through all the all the Hoops
that one jumps through when when one
creates a new program we basically use
the river valley program but just
deliver it at Nashua does that does that
answer your question
thank you
yes representative Jack thank you
following up on my colleague from
Nashville's question uh the Community
College presentation identified 3.425
million dollars in critical maintenance
so what we're doing with this
appropriation is helping them with that
amount rather than covering it
um I I would just like to and I'm sure
it's already being done
um by the system and I understand the
representatives question I like the
question and I also fully understand
that you need to do this when campus is
not there do you ever give a shout out
for the state for this money and some
I'll take you back to elementary school
poster board saying that these projects
were done on behalf of
of the school for you know from the
state
excuse me does it go in a press release
how do how does someone there who's
paying higher tuition than other states
come to realize that there is actually
uh help coming from the state
on on major Renovations where new space
is created I think we do routinely do
something like that for maintenance
as far as I know we really haven't but I
I think that that's a very good idea I
think it's important that students
understand that the state is supporting
their education in a number of different
ways I know in New Hampshire there's a
refrain that we that we hear that New
Hampshire is 50th out of 50 in state
support for public education we don't
like the message that sends to students
because New Hampshire actually supports
education in ways that may be more more
Innovative more Nimble than other states
are able to do and we appreciate that I
think that anything we can do to deliver
that message to students is something
that we should do
thank you and if you could just copy uh
copy the committee in when you come up
with some sort of press release to that
effect
we'd be appreciative you need a picture
of this good looking group we can do
that too
anything else at this point yes
representative
Shannon I just need to follow up
um on the respiratory therapy if you get
that money does it mean the program
operates exclusively out of Nashua and
River Valley discontinues or you're just
going to copy River Valley
program would continue at both locations
thank you thank you for making that
clear to me also all right any other
questions Shannon
thank you thank you very much
okay let's um
let's start in
so as I understand it
we have we have
1.6 million dollars
um
left
um and there's another 108 000 on the
other
items that we added with a hundred and
eight thousand left we'll start with
that I had a conversation with um with
Chris about if we had
um in past we've added Monies to that
and put other monies in the second part
of this
which becomes confusing to people and
departments going forward so I think
we're going to try and keep the two
items separate
yes represent Mills
um thank you Mr chair I'd like to follow
up on Representatives Jack's proposal uh
last week on items on our wish list our
agency request wish lists items 44 I'm
sorry items 45 46 and 47 for D.O.T which
are repairs to Railroad bridges on
state-owned active railroad lines
culverts on state our own lines ties and
installations there's a three separate
items and that comes up to a total of
1.67
which I think will
certainly tap our repurposed balancing
okay does everyone does everyone have
that sheet that uh represent Mills is
referring to yeah we had it from last
week it's agency requests
dated 314 2023 it was the wish list that
didn't make the big book
those line number it was 45 45 46 and
47.
are you making that as a as as a motion
represented I'm just tossing it out
there for discussion to see if whether
we have any other present projects okay
they um further discussion
yes
please the question I have is um
on the aviation Grant management
software
uh I'm just that's going to the airports
and stuff okay
as
been televised through the news of late
at our bigger airports and stuff they
have software issues that have created
safety issues and stuff like that and my
curiosity is on some of these smaller uh
airports that operate
will not upgrading this software create
other issues down the line for these
smaller less controlled environments
that are being used like in uh for
instance the Laconia Guilford airport is
a high volume jet airport and
they rely on software and stuff to keep
them functioning because they don't have
a control tower so I'm just curious if
that would undermine that by not keeping
the software upgraded or not it's more
of a question than
um and where where in our volumes here
where would I find that item
thank you
yes uh representative Jack yeah unless
Mr Shea wants to cover this I can shed
some light in this this line would be
for software to be used by the Bureau of
aeronautics
uh at the Department of Transportation
to manage the grants that are given to
airports rather than money that would
actually be spent at the airport to
upgrade their software
we have we have 25 airports in the state
some of them are federal eligible about
I think it's 12 are federal eligible and
13 are not uh the 13 that are not they
fund their own they fund their own
repairs they're typically smaller
smaller airports the federal eligible
we're on What's called the federal block
grant program which means that the
Department of Transportation administers
the federal funds that are flowing
through to the airports to do projects
and this software would help the Bureau
of Aeronautics do that work
okay
Chris did you have anything else to add
to that
uh not to that specifically I just
wanted to
um Circle back to the represent Mills
suggestion or comment
so if we do those three lines
um 45 through 47.
um I would suggest that you reduce maybe
line 46 by 25
000 to fit into the repurpose
um what's left of that repurpose
appropriation if you do that you would
spend all about three thousand dollars
of the repurposed money
I'm receptive to that and I I believe
the department would be okay with that I
think some of these are a little bit
scalable so that I think they would be
fine and they might be nodding hopefully
behind me okay and not giving me dirty
looks yes uh represent Faulkner and then
he
thank you
I remember the representatives Kaczynski
and Newton had concerns about money
being spent on Railroad lines owned by
uh Boston sand and gravel there's
subsidiary Railroad
could we describe what where this money
would go and is that different from in
locations
that were brought up by by the
representatives and
certainly I think we should explore
um
assistant commissioner
please
I believe what we're looking for is uh
some sort of explanation on
these three items on state-owned
45.647 do you have that before you sir I
do okay please I do thank you and
um just total Clarity
um this is beyond my area of expertise
um so I will answer based on the
material that that we have in the
documents be before us
um and specifically all three of these
items mentioned state-owned active
railroad line so they would be spent on
state-owned Rail lines not privately
owned Rail lines
and privately owned Airlines would be
like the scenic scenic
component
is Boston sand and gravel and
um the other line operating or the the
um through ossipy those are still
state-owned rails rail beds am I correct
I would need to confirm that that's
um I'm not familiar with with which
Railways uh state-owned and which uh
privately owned I apologize okay
but the these items that are shown
um are are items of importance to your
department I would certainly think
absolutely yes and I and I'm not in just
for my own point I'm I'm not opposed to
more care being done and hopefully
before the fact than having an issue
with Freight
Channel 9 News yeah befalling our state
has happened in others so any further
question absolutely yes representative
Jack uh thank you on that bulletin board
there there's a map of the all the Rail
lines in the state and it clearly calls
out which our state-owned active
state-owned inactive and the other ones
that are privately owned and so you can
see on which uh miles of railroad These
funds would be expended
thank you for that thank you further
questions
yes representative yeah I just want to
apologize to Mr Shea because uh when I
originally came up with that I figure I
I failed to notice that the culverts
were at 550 000 so I thought I was well
under
that so thank you very much for catching
that
all right representative
do you have any idea of what we charge
for fees or what reimbursements are or
use of the state-owned Rails
I do not
no I'm sorry in a further Ado so you
wouldn't have any idea when they were
last updated or changed
when the ties were last updated and
changed what are the fees I do not no
could you possibly
um speak to the
Railroad
aeronautic your director and come back
with that absolutely absolutely so
um my position as assistant commissioner
is responsible for the divisions of
project development and operations
um assisting or Deputy Commissioner
Brier who's been with us in the past is
um much more familiar with these areas
and of course commissioner cases as well
sounds good if it's possible for them to
get back to us today we'd sincerely
appreciate it we will do that thank you
further questions just brief thank you
thank you
Deputy Commissioner looking at the call
on these lines the culverts and the
bridges if those are not maintained
properly
flooding could occur in the area around
that line and certainly the bridge
uh there could be issues on the uh on a
roadway intersecting the railroad bridge
or going you know going underneath it
Etc
uh
is it fair to say that this is part of
the importance too it's not just for the
rail line and maybe avoiding issues with
delays on the on the rail on those rail
systems or possibly possible derailments
that these projects have additional
localized importance
that's absolutely true so keeping those
those bridges open is critical thank you
chairman
so um
of course the new members that would be
uh would you believe question as opposed
to a question so
uh there have been some chairmen that
get very disturbed on those you have one
that is not so
all right
um thank you once again
yes representative
so since we're doing Soapy's Choice yep
um
I would like to go back to the Community
College respiratory therapy program
the dollar Factor seems to sit quite
perfectly there the advantage point is
if you're doing
respiratory therapy Physical Therapy
anything along those lines it one
provides a
distinct increase in enrollment into the
institution which can also lead into
other classes at the institutions
but it's instant job placement I think a
majority of which usually stays within
the state of New Hampshire and is an
advantage to our entire Workforce tax
structure everything across the board
the
The Spill out to so many different areas
of running these programs in what the
students provide and do
uh is probably too numerous to count
here today but that would be my
suggestion for the
alleged surplus funds if we're going to
do a Sophie's Choice
thank you
further discussion representative Jack
uh thank you I just point out for
discussion's sake that the committee has
the option right now we're at
129.8 uh million of general fund bonding
the committee has the option to do both
and increase the general fund bonding by
whatever it takes to cover it that is a
that is a discussion we could have
without
suggesting whether that's a good or a
bad idea okay thank you representative
Mills uh thank you Mr chair I'd also
like to point out that we did put 1.5
million dollars already to CTE for that
program and they opted to put it into
critical maintenance instead
I would be very amenable to taking
another 1.5 million if the winner Squam
deal falls through as making that our
top priority but right now we've already
given CTE 1.5 million and they've opted
to put it to critical maintenance
instead of their Therapy Program
Community College I'm sorry
yes I'm getting confused so anyway
um so I would opt to make that a
priority for the winter Squam money if
it falls through and to still leave to
to try and distribute the excess money
appropriately in between all these
different uh departments to leave the
1.5 million at
the excess at rail thank you
representative Newman
yes
thank you
representative Eaton Sophie's Choice
that's a good characteristic or Open Mic
I guess I don't know which one is better
I'd like to throw out for consideration
excuse me some money for the Department
of Corrections for their planning for a
new Men's prison
um I think I saw in the big book they
originally had they had 50 000 that got
it 40 was in there and and on our in the
blue book here when this came through
2500 they are looking for which is a
a a pittance of what they will need
ultimately for planning but which
what kind of jumped out at me was some a
little bit of easy research last night
and I found an article
that was published through well blah
blah public radio did it and the article
was from 2019 in the broadcast and they
referenced a report from 2018 and this
is about the ceiling leaks in the prison
and I'll read the quote the ceiling in
fact has leaked for probably the past 10
to 15 years there are tarps installed to
divert the leaking water to collection
buckets reads reads the report from
September 2018. so where where I'm going
with this is
we I don't think anybody disputes that a
new prison is needed in very casual
conversations with
a few members from Finance I think
they're struggling with trying to find
funding also and so it's a I mean it's a
thing and then I remembered what
um honorable John Graham said the other
day that you do have room to go before
you do a do upset or impact
that might have been from a roofer I'm
not sure I
it so there's there's some money to go
to until you start really impacting the
bond limit but I also had read that if
you start getting a lawsuit that forces
you to legislate a new prison and fund
it no matter what you have to do that
affects your bond rating also so I see
this as a necessary thing to do thank
you thank you uh representative
uh I think we probably need some chats
down the hallway I had lunch with the
chair division one uh yesterday and my
understanding is they do have money in
the operating budget uh upwards of
around 10 million Mr Shea to deal with
us so it would 10 million bucks is going
to do a lot more than 2500 out of us
okay
um yes you can but I I would just before
we go there I have had similar
conversations in that
um the the request from the governor was
50 million dollars and when the finance
came in with uh a shortfall in the uh
the forecast
of they downgraded it to 10 million
dollars to start the process and get the
planning in order and then it's going to
become a very big decision for the
legislature going forward where we're
going to find that money we've done that
before you know it's it's a much bigger
number it needs to be done but I I feel
satisfied at this point in time that
that that needs being taken care of
tell
please follow up
I I don't know what to say I've I've had
conversations with different people than
you have I I trust your people and I
hope they do it thank you yeah
yeah if if it doesn't come if it somehow
doesn't it it's going to come it that
that money is going to come true whether
it's here or through the Senate and my
understanding is it's it's coming out of
this house proposal
further comment
all right so let's uh
let's have a let's have a discussion on
on the uh on this this
um monies and what we're going to
purpose uh these monies for
um
and I would um and we're back to the
straw poll idea here if we need to just
we need to go through this further we
will
um are you waiting to speak okay
um and I will put forward first
uh represent Mills idea to uh use our
our Surplus that we have right now
uh for items 45 46 and 47 and one of
those I believe will be adjusted back by
was it twenty five thousand dollars
which would essentially
take us out of a surplus on those lines
um and representative Mills follow-up
item was that that we would put into the
Community College as item number one
when we're looking at the possible uh
funding that may come back if when a
Squam doesn't uh doesn't
um come to terms at their school board
meeting that is our number one priority
so I guess if you're if you're in favor
of that you would raise your hands straw
Paul only at this time
a show 12 and those opposed 12 to 1.
sorry
no no
vote first okay so for for planning
purposes
um Chris if you could make that
adjustment for us
and let's let's turn the discussion now
over to in the in the event and I hope
this doesn't come to be but in the event
that when a Squam doesn't pull forward
um we're looking at a number of 7
million six four nine six three three as
I have it and we are committing 150
000 of that to the Community College 1.5
million
thank you
what is the pleasure of the committee
yes represent Faulkner they suggest that
since we're
taking it out of one
sort of educational program
that we in fact fully fund the critical
maintenance and the pulmonary program
for community colleges
out of that um
you know out of that contingency
so that would be an extra 1.9 million
for the
critical maintenance and at one point
at second that five
uh representative Jack uh looking at the
the famous sheet here if if you were to
do lines 12 13 and there's a line 13 for
it infrastructure upgrades uh so if we
were to fully fund uh lines 12 13 and 14
that would be in the spirit of
keeping it in education and that would
be a good use of some of those funds
let me just get back to that please
thank you
so that'll be 3.6 million over what
we've already
put aside
yep
we brought over we brought over 4.6 yeah
so Rose Empire's suggestion is to
bring in the rest of it was at 3 million
425 we've funded 1.5 so the balance of
that you're suggesting to bring over
that's right in addition to the
respiratory therapy respiratory there we
were we were putting that in so that's
fine the 3.4
yes representative Mr chair out
in keeping with our our this this entire
committee's
soft spots I guess you call it besides
education I'd also go to the Natural
cultural resources department and then
go ahead and fully fund
the Connecticut Lakes Headwaters Road
repairs and pavings bumping that up from
the what was it I think we put 500 500
000.
we could either put uh
we could fund them on that we could fund
that fully
so we're going to need to run some
numbers here
and can can we go backwards I just want
to go back to the community college
system
are is would
represent foxman was your suggestion
also to bring in I.T infrastructure I
hadn't suggest I suggested I didn't
think that was hard I think
representative Jack added that in when
you went through the numbers but
representative McConkey just for the
record when the department came in they
presented the I.T infrastructure and the
critical maintenance as a single
critical maintenance request
I took the detail of their request and
broke out the itps versus the critical
what would be the roofs and other HVAC
and things like that to give you the two
separate numbers
but I just wanted to be clear that when
they presented critical maintenance it
did include the it piece so yes
we're going to put in language so that
the comment system has the flexibility
to spend it
where needed isn't that correct is that
whether it be critical maintenance or
infrastructure you're saying if they hit
it as part of the same request that I
would say that it
they can decide how to
cook does everyone remember what the
infrastructure upgrades were for it
I'm just suggesting that maybe we hold
that back and make that language and
then if we have it we'll bring it back
in
you have it Shannon
if you would chin you could just go
ahead
oh
I I think I'll start and then if she
needs to jump in I guess so the it
infrastructure upgrades included
Hardware upgrades to replace equipment
at end of life for 750 000 and then life
cycle replacement of switches Network
gear and UPS
that was the detail that I had I don't
know if Shannon has additional
and for someone that uh relies on the
rest of my family for my uh
my advice on computers someone want to
tell me what i t infrastructure is
please
what what we mean by that Mr chairman
we have seven colleges within the
community college system of New
Hampshire and all rely on a shared
Central kind of I.T
infrastructure which is
which is everything from the the
hardware you know the servers and the
blades and um and I am
kind of the narrative that that we put
into our presentation here is about the
extent of my I.T knowledge to be honest
but it's it's the
the the the
what allows us to run our databases what
allows us to run all of our Building
Systems what allows us to deliver online
education all of that is is is supported
centrally by the community college
system and that is what this request
um
supports
if if our if we don't get to entirely
funding that and our request was to come
through uh to make up the balance of
item number 12 which was 3.425 which
we're already proposing half of that
then the college could make a decision
on where they wanted to spend those
funds
yes and we would we would appreciate
that flexibility
and the and the additional investment
that would um
be
deeply helpful thank you
is that okay for now and then we'll
we'll see where we go yes representative
a point of clarification on that when we
say they could use the money as they
will as far as it is under the
maintenance
are just generally use it as needs the
suggestion if I believe uh if I
understand correctly uh line 13 was
broken out of line 12. uh by Chris to uh
to show the difference between those two
and if we were to go down that road we
would develop language that said the
monies could only be used for critical
maintenance and or infrastructure
upgrades it thank you yeah we we've had
issues in the past when we've given too
much carte blanche yes thank you thank
you Mr chairman in my view the it
upgrades especially to this common data
centers in my view is critical
thank you
all right so why don't we let's put a
pencil to where we are right now and I'm
I guess I'd be are you there
so I'm I'm suggesting
um that we are
um
that we are funding potential funding
the respiratory program which was their
item
15 or excuse me 14 14.
that we are going to add another
whatever the balance is from three
million four hundred twenty five
thousand less than 1.5 million
um
what else did we have which is that I
had Connecticut Lakes for a million
United Lakes yes to finish funding that
out to the original request
so that would bring you down to 3.2
million dollars left to appropriate from
that CTE appropriation okay
yes representative Jack uh there's an
item uh for under administrative
Services number four uh for three
million dollars of Statewide parking lot
repairs and Paving
that could be added as the last priority
and would use most of that
scalable project I see where you are are
there any other suggestions before we
yeah yes please represent me I'm always
looking for return on investment in line
26 The Liquor Commission computer
software point of sale system
um they did do an upgrade uh I think
four years ago and they did it on the
cheap they had the bells and whistle
system laid out uh the point of sale
system was actually going to be able to
push advertisements onto people's
smartphones if they are within a certain
range of sales or different items going
on it was also going to accelerate the
way they
um do the sales at the register and
improve inventory
um
alignments anyway that might give a
return on the investment versus
everything else but the parking is nice
to have but um isn't necessarily going
to do what you want Chris please uh that
would be fun with liquor funds so it
wouldn't touch the CTE money that you're
trying to Reaper not repurpose but have
your wish list for
um
so I just want to make sure it's clear
that I'm not saying that your
suggestions not a valid suggestion to
the committee I just want to be clear
that if the committee acts on that it's
not going to change the 3.2 million
dollars that you're trying to
prioritize with a wish list do Chris do
you remember why because that's coming
through their their fund their dedicated
funds public Enterprise fund
yes so and did they say that they had
the funds to uh already built into their
Debt Service and their operating budget
similar to what dot had done with the
projects they presented today
so it wouldn't cost
there's no add to the operating budget
in addition to what they've been
proposed to the governor and through the
house division so far
so I we could we could bring that back
in without Peril couldn't we but not in
in here that's correct okay let's do
that does anyone have any objection to
not doing that I'm I'm sorry that we
missed that before because I was
wondering yeah we had others
all right so we'll do that
we still we have 3.2
you want to take a break for 10 minutes
3.2 remaining
right they would take so your suggestion
right Faulkner would be to bring in that
the I.T money now at this point and
reduce it from that number for the
Community College
I haven't I haven't brought over that
1.2 million right so I um
well the part we yeah we start we're
shopping on the parking lot repairs
but yeah okay
I'm I'm sorry I'm missing the point
I I I didn't know if we had disposed of
the question of whether we should
uh add money to the parking lot repairs
or whether that was still something that
we were discussing is using that 3.2
well we're just we're discussing it do
you wanna do you want to discuss that
point yes I just want to point out that
the parking lot repair uh Paving that
figure is scalable so we don't have to
give them the entire three million
dollars we can we can find other things
that we can fund fully and then whatever
is left if we'd like to or or that's a
poor way of putting it but we don't have
to give them the three the full three
million dollars for that
red Faulkner well so I would suggest
that we add two million dollars to the
parking lot repairs and then fully fund
them
Community College
okay
um yes representative Newman
the question I just want to make sure I
understand
this discussion is talking about in the
event that when a Squam does not go into
their CTE Pro okay thank you
further discussion
yes
uh Mr chairman at this time do you want
to talk about the additional requests
from uh
from Geno
um
it's all operating budget
I yeah I want to let's let's follow up
on that because I meant I meant to talk
about that so uh let's let's discuss
that so Gino had reached out and um
um and it noticed uh as of late
that um
some of his projects were not included
in the governor's uh budget that he
thought were critical to his operation
I reached out to the budget director
from the governor and and spoke to him
about that and this letter that was
distributed to folks talking about the
harbor dredging peer and maintenance
fund established
um
I believe it's the impression that there
are funds sufficient there under
um
under
um oversight by
by the state to fund his needs
so I I was I wasn't going to make any
motion to bring that forward unless you
would like to
but it is under operating funds
and capital budget overview uh Mike is
or Chris that's where that comes through
to use the peer maintenance money yes
yes they have the authority to come the
capital budget overview with requests
and you're having sat on and off and
there over the years it's always we're
always questioning how large that fund
is and what's being used and it's under
a regular uh
it's under regular review and I to to
the times I've been on that board
committee there's always
it's always been permitted
yes go right ahead uh thank you
um
it seems at different times we do uh we
do fun dredging
like at the uh we we did in in Rye in in
Hampton
so that I guess at times you know we do
that and also with the with the Turning
basin
um
I I don't know how big the their
dredging fund is uh finally we seem to
be dipping into it or asking for some
help somehow but okay thank you yeah and
it was also relayed that there are uh
more Federal funding possibilities out
there to help them with that project so
um
there there wasn't a concern from the
governor's office that we didn't have
sufficient funding
reps emails
okay I want to go over something out and
with Mr Shea's uh approval on this this
is what I've come up with if we go to
the community college system right now
their line item for respiratory therapy
and forget the titles just pay attention
to the dollar figures is 1.5 million
which we have already allocated to them
so their leftover needs are critical
maintenance and it infrastructure which
is
4.625 million dollars in addition to
that we've we've tentatively agreed to
put in a million towards the natural
cultural resources Connecticut Lakes
headquarters
for a total of
5.625 million dollars so that's where we
are and we've also discussed parking lot
repairs giving them some money uh not a
dollar figure yet but at this point in
time Mr Shea I've got
5.625 that we've come up with that's
correct thank you just wanted to be on
the same page at this point in time with
dollars and Liquor Commission is off the
table because that's an Enterprise
funding but we where are we able to
bring it we're able to bring it back in
definitely the committee can vote to do
that project it's not going to count
against your general fund
um debt limit or it's or against the um
repurposing or the CTE money if that
needs to happen yeah I would I would
want to bring that in yeah
so our our balance now is at what it's
you have just over 2 million and I think
represent Faulkner had said suggested
that you could use that Das scalable
money to make up the difference
if the committee had that desire but you
may have other options that you want to
consider
what's the pleasure of the committee are
we are we amicable to
putting the rest in representative
Cloutier yes a question again this is on
the wish list is that correct correct
correct and I just again I
representative could you repeat the
total figure that you reached I'm I'm
still trying to follow the debate here
at this point we're at
5.625 million dollars
five point two five points five five
million six hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars okay and that would be
on the wish list is that correct that's
the that's off of the wish list and this
is if when a Squam falls through on the
vote okay thank you
further discussion before I go to straw
poll yes representative
yeah I'm not trying to beat a dead horse
I just want to ask you again you are
somewhat confident that
some planning money for the uh for a new
prison will be available
yes and I I had us I had a friend that
told me we can always beat a dead horse
so don't worry so and if if if this
wouldn't be the vehicle if that money
had to be found anyway so you know
because I see that I had just seen the
the requests that came through ours for
the 2 million thank you yeah my
understanding is we're perfectly fine
there
yes representative
um just to clarify
um
if the winter Squam uh CTE project
doesn't get approved and it keeps saying
the floor is that the floor of the
legislature by Vote or is that the uh
the ballot that's going forth locally
for them to approve the 10.2 million
to to approve their their uh portion of
that fund okay it um my understanding is
it lost by six or eight votes last time
and they've worked extremely hard uh
trying to get consensus in the community
they've had almost uh I was told by the
director
um they've been holding public uh
education on this and there's still
another one this week and the vote is on
the 27th so our wish list may be for
naught and it's our hope that that does
become the case but if for some reason
it doesn't here's where we want those
items to go
does that requires sixty percent vote of
the populace is that what they're
looking for that's that's my
understanding those are often if
represent Jack thank you most of the
time that they will choose to fund that
with bonding which is a super majority I
would also point out that by the time
household 25 comes to the floor we they
will presumably have taken that vote so
we will know the answer
uh before it comes to the floor
Chris and just to make sure that
everybody understands the wish list that
you're putting forward wouldn't replace
the CTE project as passed by the house
what you're doing is you're letting the
Senate know when they get House Bill 25
if the CTE project isn't approved
locally that this is your priority this
is the house position that you'd want to
take those funds and move them into
these wish list areas it doesn't bind
the Senate to do that in any way the
Senate would make its own choices but
when you came to a committee a
conference you'd be able to point back
to this and say this was one of our
highest priorities and this we let you
know that so can we negotiate around
that versus not having anything in
writing
so we've gone through a tentative wish
list
um now that we're at that point I'd like
to Circle back to representative jacks
comment when we started
which is the state treasurer comes in
and gives you a number
that we try to backfill the state
treasurer by design by history everyone
we've ever had always does a low ball to
feel excessively comfortable
and this committee uh numerous times
over history
has decided that the priorities were
greater than what the number the state
treasurer gave
and if you took what we've approved so
far minus the paving
um
you're under a five percent I think of
four percent something
increase over what the state treasurer
gave you as a total and this committee
could easily fund everything in that
wish list and not do anything that would
make anyone scream over the capital
budget bonding
but
in in my terms and I believe you've been
here the same or if not more
we had one time we we have done that on
several occasions
um on other times we have we have stayed
with our number
just for the committee's information if
you look at the compare sheet that I
gave you earlier
if you turn to page five
and you go to row 147
and you're going to see a number of 129
million
that's where you're at right now the
governor was at 129 million 875 637.
based on what I gave you the amendment
this morning you were at 129 766-701
so you're just slightly under what the
governor's proposed but to
representative Eaton's point if you were
to add any of this wish list it would
take you over the 130 million dollar
mark
and I just wanted to put that out there
for the committee so you understand
where you're Where You Are
right and I and I I fully understand
um and I'm sure most of the committee
does on that and they to represent
beaton's Point
um five seven million
um does not does not break the uh does
not get the the nerves
I I just
my my only hesitation on this is that
there is so much that Finance is dealing
with and what they had to cut out that
it's I don't know whether it should be
us that makes that push or whether it's
them and what that wish list is going to
look like
um to make up for some of the shortfalls
that we have been talking about
I
I we looked at it back and forth how to
do this whether we would we would just
uh fund everything we wanted and then
put the uh the second Community uh or
the second Career Technical School off
to the side and we decided we'd go this
way so
um
let's let's finish up
um on the on where we are and then we're
going to come back to that okay and I'm
probably going to take a break for 10
minutes and then we'll come back to that
so what the pleasure the pleasure of the
committee on uh the items which
basically expends where we are
in using the balance for um
um
parking lot parking lot
repairs and replacement
um which was the last item we spoke of
um it if you're in favor of that and if
you need more explanation we can do it
now but if you're in favor of that which
essentially takes our balance to near
zero signified by raising your hand
thank you all right so let's uh
so we're to that point if we could take
uh 10 minutes and then we will uh
continue
watching anyone in the room
um if you look at this
all right let's let's come back from our
extended break here
um for the some committee members I
don't know if you're aware
um and I'm sure the gentleman won't have
an issue
um I'm hoping not uh representative
Connor on his way in on Wednesday had a
car accident and totaled his car
my last conversation with him was that
he was personally fine but that's that's
why he hasn't been here and if you're
listening on the broadcast we wish you
best and if you can get back to me on
your health at this point
all right
all right so
we started a conversation earlier by
um
represent beggar about wanting to bring
in
three Highway projects
and I'm going to turn the conversation
over representative Edgar to tell you
what those projects are
these are are Highway funds the
department will speak to the point but
it won't affect our bonding ability on
on the
uh-huh
on our total budget here they're needed
items and I don't see a problem with
bringing them in here uh it's sort of
like how we just discovered on the
Liquor Commission which of course is the
Enterprise fund that but it won't have
an issue on us and I'd turn to
representative beggar to discuss that
uh thank you Mr chairman
uh yes the uh the items that I'd like to
bring forth were
three of the items at the transportation
department had had put in for but we
haven't considered yet they were not
um they were submitted to the governor
but it wasn't of the ones that he had
approved
and again I guess I want to emphasize
that these are the highway funds
um they're not coming out of the general
fund and they've already have it in in
their budget to handle the
the costs
um the first one is the Statewide
construct salt and
sand sheds and uh we uh
we're familiar with the the request uh
for these over the years they're always
trying to to fix the ones that they have
and they have so many of them that they
try to do so many every couple of years
um and that amount was for for two and a
half million
um the second one was undergrad fuel
storage tank replacement
um they have still have a a lot of
underground storage tanks and they're
going about replacing them uh you know
before they have a problem they have a
regular schedule for it so I I believe
we want to keep up uh doing that so that
we we don't have a problem and it's a
lot more expensive if you do have a
problem with them and every place in
them uh with uh you know the double wall
tanks and they have monitor situate you
know stuff with them so we can actually
tell if it's a problem and I think and
again that was for two and a half
million
and the last one is for this Statewide
crew quarters if you look at some of the
pitches that they provided in the
handout that they gave us
you know uh some of the places that they
have right now are ones that you know we
might not want to sleep in a lot
um and they
they have uh you know the situations
that they you know the crews are working
overnight in these snowstorms and other
times and they really have to stay there
and so we have to just to try to make it
better for the uh for the crew people
that are working for us and uh and so
that they can um you know be safer when
they're out on the road and everything
so uh they're continually trying to uh
upgrade their crew quarters they have a
lot to have a lot of work to do and they
have a request right now and for five
million so that's a total of uh 10
million dollars against the highway fund
and I hope uh I hope the committee will
consider it
thank you
yes represent bogert
would that be items 4950 and 51 that
we're talking about
because item 49 for the Salton sheds is
uh two million 17
000 not
2 million five hundred thousand
is that correct
I'm going by their original request
um so if if the the latter the one that
you just mentioned is is more
appropriate then that's uh
um trying to go by what uh this
information this information I had not
not this I probably should have gone by
what you have right in front of you
which is the uh
the list of uh additional agency
requests
yes and that's and
represent I mean that's
um Edgar that is the numbers that you
just provided going off the additional
agency requests
I actually went off of the uh original
request uh sorry so uh if I if I could
check with the the the department uh if
which one is the one that you really
requested now
represent most you want to say something
for him yeah I believe what
representative Edgar was talking about
was line 49 50 and 51. our figures are
currently the requests are for 2 million
17 500 for the salt and sand sheds
I'm only going to say that once
the underground fuel tank replacement
was two million dollars and the
Statewide crew quarters was five million
dollars for a total of nine million
seventeen thousand five hundred dollars
press right
no that confirms what the agency
submitted and they're still okay with
that number okay
it's in the book that they provided you
when they came before you I know the
original request might have been
something different
I could I could read the original
question
that's fine um
so my my question to you Chris is if we
and we're about to straw poll this if we
bring these items in this 9 million plus
dollars
um that does not affect our our bond
that we're going to pass out here under
General funds it does not because the
highway funds would pay that portion
okay
and the agency has testified that
they've
um
accounted for this these projects in
their debt service line in their
operating budget and to date that hasn't
been removed
okay
so that's that's fine I'd just like to
make one one on item 51 Statewide crew
quarters I had I had visited several
with uh executive counselor Kenny over
the last couple three years and this
item keeps coming up and life safety
issues and everything else and then for
the crews that uh have to have no other
choice because they don't know when it's
going to stop snowing have to have a
place to sleep
they'd been using wood stoves and things
that they they can't use anymore
we have hiring
issues everywhere in the state but every
every crew member that I ever spoke to
always talked about the importance of
this so strongly support that the other
two go without saying so if if you're in
favor of a straw poll batting four
eyelines 49 50 and 51 off the additional
agency request signify by raising your
hand
we show unanimous thank you I'd like to
go back to representative Eaton perhaps
you would like to uh we spoke about it
and adding the one million five hundred
thousand dollars for the computer
software for the Liquor Commission but I
never brought that to a vote perhaps
you'd like to motion that
Mr chair I'd moved the one million
dollars for the point of sale system
computer software under the Enterprise
funds
one million five or one million yep
that would be
that would be line 26. okay 1 million
five hundred thousand
if you're in favor of that again that's
in that's not you know that's a separate
fund Enterprise fund uh signified by
raising a hand
and we show that we are unanimous in
that and Mr chair before the
Transportation uh folks leave uh
possible to ask one last question
please
missed Cass I know you're doing cleanup
at this point but how is your team
holding up and how did you survive the
Avalanche since I'm in an area where we
got the jackpot
Dave you can chime in so uh I think most
of the state did pretty pretty well
um by Tuesday Morning things were black
and wet the Southwest area still had a
lot of trees down power lines down I
know they were still busy all day uh
Tuesday cleaning up but I think they've
you probably saw coming coming in today
they've got on top of it
um it was definitely a lot of uh it was
it was it was a long couple of nights
and a lot of challenges over over there
with the amount of snow they had had
gotten some of the traffic and truck
truck
knives and accidents and stuff but um
yeah so I think they I think very very I
you know even with the amount of snow to
have it have it have it turned around in
in a matter of a day uh I think they did
an exemplary work keeping on top of
everything so
and your crews are doing okay they are
yeah they're tired but I think they're
wrestling today and stuff Dave do you
have any other more recent reports we
talked to the district engineer Tuesday
morning and um you know they were still
out clearing up some of the trees down
and wires down but I think people were
um you know holding up anything more
yeah no and Mr chair if you would concur
I would ask that on behalf of you and
the committee that Mr Cass extends his
thanks and gratitude for a hard fight
for the last several days certainly
great no I appreciate that I certainly
will be glad to have that recognition
and perhaps you don't have the answer
now that let's say it stops snowing
tomorrow and we stop having ice events
how how are you and your winter
maintenance budget overall
we have a um item going for governor
Council uh next week for about another
six million dollar transfer
um we are over expended in some uh line
items primarily salt and the um hired
hired equipment that we are
paying right now out of some other other
lines until they can be back filled
um
we need to review typically Friday when
we get the payroll and stuff we'll we'll
be making sure that that six million
dollar uh transfer for winter
maintenance is adequate to
um with with the with the amount of
expenditures from the last the last
storm but um
yeah so we had
about a month and a half ago had done a
three and a half million dollar transfer
and then it had a long week of storms
the very end of February beginning of
March and this past storm I had a lot of
uh
time and overtime but um so we'll be
we'll be looking at those numbers but uh
yeah okay excuse Mr chairman can I have
one quick question thank you will this
be from the general fund these transfers
you've asked for now the transfers are
from the highway fund Highway fund
unrestricted from the highway fund
Surplus oh sir Highway fund Surplus
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
turnpike I should say this this uh about
a million dollars of that transfer is
also in in um
relative to the turnpike system and
that's out of the turnpike fund
representative Jewish but just brief
thank you chairman just briefly
commissioner
is there anything different about this
year compared to last year is it the
trees
uh that in terms of asking for the storm
is different what's different this year
compared to last year and why some of
the car is that inflation costs are up
so you know we had our our budget based
on cost of of salt and stuff from from
2000 and
20 2021
um we've seen a lot of material cost
escalation
um that's a big part of driving some of
the
um
with some of the you know fund funds
requests so I think you know as as what
as we're tracking we're seeing average
winter or maybe slightly at more
um average usage uh but because the cost
of the Commodities is is has increased
um we're seeing higher than average cost
thank you the best of the cruise thank
you thank you thanks Jim
thank you all right I think we can now
excuse you thank you thank you for
coming over
all right we're going to
um we're going to switch gears here a
little
uh representative brought up a
conversation uh earlier
that we were we were presented by the
treasurer
um a number that has been very closely
aligned with what we've been given in
past years on our goal of what to spend
which was
a hundred and what was our Chris our
number we were
so so when the treasurer comes before
you with their debt affordability study
she does that at 120 million right now
the um decisions you've made or is it
129 million which is in line with what
the governor had done
I believe you've heard from the
treasurer in the if not recently in the
you have heard it in the past that
um
going up above 130 by a few million
dollars isn't necessarily going to
change that debt affordability number by
very much it might be a couple tenths of
a point but it's not going to put it up
in the area where they would be
concerned the other thing I would just
note is that the decision on how much
you bond is your decision the treasurer
doesn't tell you or limit that she just
comes in and provides advice on what the
impact might be
thank you uh in in past
um
Capital budgets coming out of here there
have been several times that if if not
more than that after we have listened to
the budget requests from all the
Departments and um
that we've come to a conclusion that it
would be to the benefit of the state
that we would uh we would we would go
above that recommended threshold by the
treasurer it's ultimately our decision
um what I'm going to propose is that
after all that hard work we had to find
out where we would possibly spend seven
million dollars is going to be my
recommendation Now That We Roll those
out of the wish list and bring them into
the capital budget increasing our
capital budget request by that seven
million dollars there's more to that but
and in the event
were not to be funded
than our request then that bonding would
drop by that that seven million dollar
also so the treasurer has said in the
past if you move the needle five seven
even ten that's probably not an issue
but when you start kicking out beyond
that point and especially it's somewhere
around the 20 million dollar figure that
it could cause concern
um and
so at this point in time uh is is there
any discussion on talking about doing
that yes representative over please
just a point of clarification for my
understanding
if when a Squam is accepted then we're
looking at making the capital budget
seven million dollars more to take into
account all the things we just discussed
and if when a Squam fails
then that seven million dollars would
come back from the capital and go back
in as our uh projects that we wish to
have no
no what were what were what we're con
planning and I'm sure Chris can say it
more eloquently than I can we're taking
our wish list that we just agonized over
and part of the Aggregates because they
are definite needs and they they fall in
the same priorities that we have always
passed out of here instead of keeping
that as a wish list on the side
and letting other places decide whether
they agree with our wish list or not
we're going to move them over into the
capital budget and then in the event
that when a Squam was not funded then
our total request would be reduced by
seven million dollars
plus or minus plus am I correct
sort of I'm close you you are close so
you would pass a budget that the Senate
would need to remove that piece related
to the one escorm CTE
if they didn't do that then it would
stay at the number that you passed that
the house passed it at but I what I
believe that the chair is suggesting is
that if when a Squam doesn't the
communities that need to vote on that
don't get the numbers they need the
Senate will likely take it out it
becomes a kind of a non-discussed item
but what leaves behind is all the things
that the house would like to have funded
and they are funded in your budget
versus being on the wish list which is
that we hope you put it in for us but we
didn't fund it ourselves
so it
maybe strengthens your debate when when
it comes time to look at your capital
budget compared to what the Senate comes
up with
representative the good thing is that
the Senate doesn't take it out
and it doesn't get done because it's a
lack of local approval the money never
gets spent and it gets
you know lapses and
never never actually impacts the state
budget
I'd agree with that but I'd also back
you up one step and that you'd go to a
committee a conference and you would ask
to have it removed so it would it would
end up it would end
up being removed by the time you got
done with the legislative process
any other discussion
okay
I think we should do a straw poll that
uh
if if you're in agreement of the
suggestion of bringing the items that we
had listed
we're about seven million where were we
Chris on that yeah so it'd be 7.625
million and just to remind the members
it would be the respiratory lab for 1.5
million
the balance of the critical maintenance
for ccsnh for 1925 plus the I.T
infrastructure for ccs and H which is
1.2
a million dollars for the Connecticut
lakes and then
um
being the roads correct yeah the
Connecticut like Paving the road
projects so to add to the 500 that
you've already provided thank you
and that would get you the 7.625 million
all right should everyone understand
yes representative
that was line item 35 on the wish list
we took it from a million five to a
million
so on you no you're going to end up in a
million five so right now in the
amendment I handed out this morning you
had five hundred thousand dollars in it
your action today would bring it to
fully funded at 1.5 million
all right everyone understands
straw poll if you're in favor of that
signify raise your hand
it shows the committee is unanimous
I appreciate the hard work that's been
done by this committee I think our
position strong
um and um
we will send it off to you Chris to form
you know work out the details
so I will get a new Amendment drafted
um and have it I'll email it to the
members over the weekend hopefully
tonight
so before you start celebrating
um so that you can see what will come
I'll come in with hard copies on Monday
morning
you meet at 10 o'clock to do any further
work that you might need to do and then
if there's any issues with the amendment
let me know
and then at 11 o'clock I believe you
have your exact session on House Bill
25.
yes representative Jack I have completed
reviewing the lamps extension section in
the draft Amendment and I find it
correct
thank you
any other further questions
okay thank you we will we will be back
here on Monday morning
once again Monday morning at 10 right
correct for the work session and an 11
A.M for the executive session it's um I
know I know there's one one person or so
that's told us that they can't be here
um I would really hope that we can put
as many bodies in our chairs that day
and uh so that we can have a unanimous
yeah we are certainly looking for
unanimous and we will talk to that point
when we when we meet next
thank you
uh folks if I can hold you for one
moment
there there is there is one other
important item that we need to take care
of
and it is the um
uh item number 18 Winnipesaukee River
Basin upgrade we had discussed it and I
thought we had taken a straw poll on it
um
and uh this is this is the same
Chris you want to take us through this
item number 18 River Basin upgrade six
million seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars so as the committee might recall
the Department of Environmental Services
came in requesting this Capital project
the department is um
the body that oversees the Winnipesaukee
River Basin that serves I believe it's
10 communities in The Lakes Region area
excuse me and those communities
basically have all their waste come to a
central point which is the river
Winnipesaukee River Basin and it's
processed these 10 communities have a
advisory committee that the Des works
with and when they need to do Capital
work or operational work they get
approval from this advisory committee
so the department is indicated the
advisory committee is aware of and has
agreed to the 6.7 million dollars in
infrastructure improvements having to do
with pumping stations and
um lines getting to move the material
you know getting those updated or fixed
um
so that that's essentially what it is
the because it is other funds The Debt
Service will be paid for by the fees
that are collected from the communities
as it relates to the use of the winter
uh
Winnipesaukee River Basin system
so it doesn't impact the general fund
bonds that you would be issuing
representative yes I move that we put
this into the capital budget uh this
amount which is under uh it's not on the
general fund I believe and the total is
six million seven hundred fifty thousand
seven hundred fifty thousand dollars
winnosapi River Basin upgrade I moved we
put it in
further discussion
straw poll if you're in favor of that
and I apologize I thought we'd put this
in earlier
uh shows unanimous
Chris is there anything else the
chairman might have forgot that we need
to taken care of yeah
no I think that addresses everything
that you had mentioned to me
to remind you of all right
thank you all right well uh we are we
are done today with our work thank you